hey everyone is cereth register nurse
sorry and calm and in this video i'm
going to demonstrate how to check the
urine for glucose and protein which is
done during prenatal visits so why don't
we check the urine of a pregnant woman
for glucose and proteins
well pregnant women are at risk for
gestational diabetes and preeclampsia
and I have some videos over those topics
if you would like to review those but
we're looking for glucose in the urine
because this could indicate gestational
diabetes and we're looking for protein
which could indicate that the woman may
be developing preeclampsia so you'll
want to of course perform hand hygiene
dawn some gloves you'll need the
specimen provided from the pregnant
woman you'll also need a test strip and
you'll need the diagram because you'll
be referencing this test strip with
these colors so I've performed hand
hygiene and I'm donned gloves now we're
going to take this test strip and we are
simply just going to dip it in the urine
like this and then we are going to take
it and lay it like this and we're gonna
wait for one minute and read results so
it's been a minute now we're gonna take
our test strip and we're going to
compare it with the little color key the
top one is the glucose and based on our
color it is normal for glucose the
bottom one is checking for protein and
based on its color it is negative for
protein after you interpret the results
you want to dispose of the urine per
your facility's protocol Dolf your
gloves and perform hand hygiene okay so
that wraps up this video on how to check
the yearn for protein and glucose and be
sure to also check out our other videos
that demonstrate nursing skills and the
maternity reviews